it's hard to understand what's going on
I mean I really you know one minute you
feel like oh my gosh this is gonna be
now the landslide is gonna start and
then there'll be some other weaselly
little you know sidestep they do or
whatever it is and you know this this
administration is a is a is a rabid dog
and it's turning us upside down and all
you know as far as I'm concerned it's as
obvious as the nose on your face
you know but people have made this these
elections and politics it in general who
they are and it's not who you are
you can make a bad decision about a
candidate it's not who you are it
doesn't mean you're dumb it doesn't mean
you're different
it doesn't mean you know the trouble
with what's happening right now is these
you know these really negative forces
like the Steve bannon's of the world are
convincing us that we're separate that
we're not the same country that there's
two countries there's not two countries
I can I can break bread with anybody in
this country I love people in this guy I
love the heartland of this country it is
has nothing to do with that it has to do
with it's become obvious that the choice
was a bad one we just need to change it
and if you if you can't vote for a
Democrat at least let all this flood of
information that's that's so negative
and so obvious keep you home